- This video, right now,
what I'm saying right this second,
is being watched 30 years after my death.
Right now this is being watched.
Hey everyone.
(audience laughing)
Sorry we didn't get to meet.
You were born too late.
You know, but like, you know
I'm really pissed I'm dead.
(upbeat jazz music)
Hey guys, today was a
really good one in Vegas.
Great key note, great
podcast, I really liked it.
Like, I liked the keynote
more than DRock did.
I told him it was a special one.
As a matter of fact, please
leave in the comments YouTube
if you felt like if you saw what I saw,
which was some nuanced
differences in this talk.
Think, I made the reference to DRock,
I normally throw a 101
mile an hour fastball,
today I threw a 97 mile an hour fastball,
and I'm hoping that means
a couple of you can hit it,
or will hit it.
So good day.
Headed back.
Jets, Cowboys tomorrow.
Jets are so banged up, I'd
like to make a prediction
that this is gonna be our
first win and stun the boys,
but I'm not sure I can totally go there.
It'll be fun to see in the
comments what actually happened,
'cause I'm still worried
about the offensive line
and certain parts of the receiving core.
But none the less, very good day.
DRock, it's been nice
spending some time together.
- [DRock] A lotta, lotta.
- Lotta time, lotta time, see ya.
♪ Good Lord ♪
♪ All I wanna do is put on ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ All I wanna do is put
on, put on, put on ♪
♪ No doubt, no doubt ♪
Vegas, Saturday morning, speaking
to 2,000 mortgage brokers
which are really entrepreneurs
and sales people.
Going for a little bit of a
different approach in my mind.
I told DRock that it's gonna be different.
♪ Grooving in the Cadillac
with cruise control ♪
♪ Doing what I do you know ♪
(audience cheering)
This is important how
many people here under 35?
Just raise your hands.
Kids listen to me.
(audience laughing)
This is not that long ago, this is 1997.
(audience clapping)
Listen to me, this is me on a panel
only 23 years ago, right,
when you were 13 or younger,
and I'm sitting debating
which is more powerful.
The Yellow Pages,
(audience laughing)
or the entire internet.
And by a wide margin,
I lost the debate to
the 40 people listening.
(audience laughing)
One nice man in his 50s was like,
"Hey, real quick, so how does this work?"
This is literally what he asked me,
I just really want to understand.
What I'm doing right now is
contextualizing everybody
how far we've come to let you understand
where this is about to go,
and why it's so important
for you to really get serious about this.
This gentleman asked me,
if the way I shipped
wine through the internet
was taking a bottle from the liquor store,
and in the basement
there was some weird pipe
I put it into, and it went to people.
(audience laughing)
(hands clapping slowly)
♪ I mean we was just sitting
back you know, chopping it up ♪
♪ Reminiscing about the
good old days and all that ♪
- Happy to be here.
- I totally buy into what
you're saying about content
putting everything out.
- Okay
- I'm a private person that
I love to put out things
that help people grown.
- Good.
- But there's a part of me
that I want to keep private.
- Brother, I've never
posted a piece of content
on my family.
Everybody posts everything
about their family
'cause it gets likes.
You're 100% in control,
good, don't post it.
- Totally get that.
- Okay
- But when I see influencers,
when I see people
that just have a camera
crew following them.
- That works for them,
the fuck has to do with you?
(audience laughing)
- Well, that's why I'm asking.
- Like, what I do, or somebody else does,
or influencer does, or
what works for her or him
has nothing to do with that, with you.
If it doesn't work for you,
it's gonna break anyway.
There's no right way to do it,
there's the right way for you to do it.
Talk about bananas all
day I don't give a shit.
(audience laughing)
You don't need to talk about
your private life, I don't.
I don't talk about my private life at all.
I meant it when I said earlier
had I not been in this business,
it's the story of my life,
I didn't drink any alcohol
'cause Nancy Reagan
got to my mom.
(audience laughing)
So alcohol and drugs like
I was clean as a whistle.
If my Dad wasn't in the liquor business,
I know, for fact, I would've
never drank alcohol in my life.
And I know, for fact,
had I not been in the
communications business,
I'd be sitting in the audience today
with not a single social media profile
'cause I have nothing to share with you.
♪ Way back ♪
♪ It's time to go way back,
way back, way back, way back ♪
♪ You see, in retrospect I
would've did it the same ♪
♪ Aha ♪
♪ In hind sight I'm
the only one to blame ♪
♪ I aint picky I'm just real specific ♪
- You're awesome by the way.
- Thank you brother.
- I'll walk with you.
- Okay.
- This is a personal question
I was the next one in line, I missed it.
It's a weird thing, I grew up dirt poor
like dirt fucking poor.
- Yeah.
- Like nothing.
- Yeah yeah.
- So when I was 16 I moved out on my own.
- Yeah.
- Started my life and everyday, you know,
my dad was a steel worker,
my mom was a drug addict
she overdosed, she died.
- I'm sorry.
- It was probably best.
- Yeah, I understand.
- But everyday I woke up, I said,
"I'm not going to be like that."
- Right--
- I'm gonna be--
- that became your driver, I understand.
- So, but, now today,
- Yeah.
- I have a 100 million
dollar appraisal company.
I do the appraisals for
almost everybody out there.
- Good for you.
- It's awesome.
And super successful,
great company, real happy.
But every single day I wake up,
I still feel like that
little fucking poor boy.
- Well, that's good.
- I hate it.
- Well, okay, so then you need to,
if you hate it you need to go deeper.
You need to go either into
therapy, I mean this is real,
like you got to get the poison out.
- I just, successful
company. successful person.
- Successful isn't
this, successful's this.
- But I'm happy with my wife,
I'm happy with my kids
- Great.
- we have a great family.
So are you tired of having
the chip on your shoulder,
or is it deeper than that?
- I'm just tired of having
a chip on my shoulder.
- Yeah, I mean look, I
think the question becomes,
I believe, here's what I
believe, and I could be wrong.
I believe that you can't do
this to your wife or others,
this is why I believe in
therapy or some other version,
or some other version if
you have a stigma on that.
Here's what I believe.
I believe people don't realize
by actually saying something out loud
and getting the poison out.
I believe there's three to four things
that are deeply inside of you,
that you've never said at all,
that are completely predicated
on your mom dynamics,
that the second they come
out of your fucking mouth,
whether on an Instagram
video to the world,
'cause you're like fuck it,
I'm going to tear this
whole thing down or,
- Can I ask you to move--
- Yup,
or by going and sitting with
somebody in a private room,
or however the fuck you, or
going to a fucking forest
by yourself and screaming
it at the top of your lungs.
I don't care how you do it,
I promise you without
knowing all the details,
there's poison in you that
you've never said out loud.
- I'm sure.
- I'm sure too.
- Like, just saying
this, was hard.
- I could see it.
- Yeah.
- Brother, what, nobody's
gonna judge you on that,
like, this is why I always tell people,
put out all their fucking skeletons,
'cause that's the fucking jail.
There's no amount of money
and success you're gonna make
that's going to fix that.
You've got to get the poison out.
- Yeah.
- You've got to get
the fucking poison out.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Got it,
- Thank you.
- get the poison out bro.
- I mean it.
You know, I'm telling you.
- Can we get a selfie?
- Of course.
- [Woman] Thank you.
- You got me shaking that was good shit.
- It's real.
- Yeah.
- It's real, it's what it is.
- Thank you.
- Success doesn't cover it.
- Yeah, it's not the money.
- It's not the outside it's the inside.
And what's scary is just
getting it out of your mouth.
I've watched so many fucking
people win that game,
but it's hard.
The reason it's still there,
bro, the reason it's still
in there is 'cause it's hard.
If it's so easy you'd say it right now.
- You always think getting
successful will make it go away--
- It won't.
'Cause people think the outside fixes it,
it's the inside.
- [Man] Right this way.
(melancholy music)
(upbeat piano music)
- So as a working mother,
- Yes.
- it's very difficult to
prioritize everything.
And I have a very crazy
passion to grow my business.
I have five only, five
people, like on the team.
I'm small I want to grow rapidly
but, I tried doing things.
- That--
- I tried it.
- No, no, rapidly.
Rapidly's the problem.
- The reason; the reason
you have friction,
the reason you have a question right now,
is being a working mother,
having crazy ambition,
and being a mother, should eliminate,
and has to eliminate
the concept of rapidly,
and this is where everybody gets caught.
You don't realize and this is what I,
you know I talk about this,
I know you watch my content.
- I know.
- You don't know how young you are.
- I feel like grandma.
- I get it, but you're wrong, you're not.
- I feel like 15 years
of grind I been doing,
and I tried doing social media,
I tried doing like, going up to realtors
and be like, "Hey use our services,
"I'm a mortgage broker I'm better."
They'll give me their hardest transaction,
for like, hardest transaction
nobody else can do
and they'll take away the business.
But, how do I prove it, like,
"Dude, I did that, like c'mon."
- By by communicating it to
the world and by being patient.
15 years is not as long as you think.
- I know.
- It's not.
Everyone's like, "Oh, I wanna
be an entrepreneur like you."
I'm like, I truly started at six, truly.
Lemonade, shoveling snow,
washing cars like truly at six.
I'm 37 years in and I'm,
I actually it's funny,
I brought it up today
which I don't do often,
which is like man. 43 year
old me is a lot better
than 22 year old me.
Even though 22 year old
me was a, natural talent,
and it's funny when I listen
to all time great athletes,
you know, I listen to like Kobe, LeBron,
and they talk about that.
Like, they talk about like I'm 33 now
there's certain things I can't do,
but there's so much more I can.
You have 35, 40 more years.
- Yeah.
- It's the
word rapidly when it
came out of your mouth
is the tell, it's like poker.
It's when I know that you're in trouble.
You need to slow it down.
- Got to learn,
- Got to learn.
- Practice.
- That's right
practice. I think the biggest thing,
is about relationship with time.
And when you have ambition,
my man Chris really is, you know,
it's why I keep looking at him.
Like, his ambition,
what he's trying to achieve is a big deal.
It really matters.
Again, I reference it,
at the top of the list
of the things that I get
private messaged about.
The men and women that
service our country,
till they keep us safe,
that are dealing with
the mental health issues,
they're dealing with, it's a big one.
But he'll fail if he tries to go too fast
or tries to boil the ocean.
It's too big.
I wanna change everyone's lives.
If I even think about that I'll fail.
I just got to do what I can
and then when I'm 98, 92,
113 whenever it's a wrap,
I get to, look I left it on the field.
What we all have though,
is we now can have legacy
'cause of what Nicole, DRock,
everybody and Drew are doing.
Like, this video right now,
what I'm saying right this second,
is being watched 30 years after my death.
Right now this is being watched,
Hey, everyone.
Sorry we didn't get to meet,
you were born too late.
You know but, like, I'm
really pissed I'm dead.
But, that's real.
- Yeah.
- Like, that's real.
So, slow it down.
(mellow piano music)
I think that those are the
two things that matter.
I think there is upfront,
I think about things in extremes
and finding balance within them.
So, you know, using technology
to communicate at scale makes sense.
I'm probably on the way to
the airport now in Vegas,
make a video and I'm gonna press a button
in my community app, which
is a new text messaging app
that I'm in the alpha or beta of.
And it's going to text
125,000 people in one shot.
I'm not sending it one-by-one.
However, as soon as that goes out,
a bunch of people are gonna
be like "is this really you?"
Or they're going to say something
about the content I said,
and then I'm gonna go
one-by-one and be like,
"Neil, it's me, like it
really was me, I sent this,"
or, "Sally, no, your
issue with thought process
"or with Facebook strategy
or with management is this."
So I love scale but I
think that non scalable
is the equal dancing partner to it.
And I believe people think
it's one or the other.
So I'm more of the mindset
of 51/49 non scalable,
because I do think that human variable
is the decision maker
in a service business.
I wanna make a positive
impact on the world.
It's very important to me.
My gratitude of the circumstances
and the parenting that I was given.
My way of doing that is not
how everybody tells me to do it
which is go fight on Twitter.
My way is to instill things
like gratitude, and empathy,
and kindness and patience.
That's how I plan on doing it.
I'm not worried about boiling the ocean.
One day at a time, one day at a time,
one day at a time and then you wake up
40 years later and
you've created a legacy.
(high intensity music)
Think we should take this off?
Maybe they'll give
something funny by accident.
How are you sir?
- Good, Good.
- Real pleasure.
- [Women] I love it.
- Good job.
- Real pleasure, take care.
- Hey Gary, I think,
we have to make this the last question.
- Are you sure?
I still see 5:26.
- Three more.
- Four more.
- We'll keep going.
- Yeah, keep going.
- Next question please.